being a citizen of the european union
means that many aspects of our lives are
regulated by a weird entity
it feels like a huge bureaucracy is
making decisions over our heads
many europeans think that their vote in
the eu elections doesn't count and that
the eu is not democratic
how democratic is the eu really and does
your vote actually achieve anything
in democratic states public policies are
based on the will of the people
but the people are not a coherent thing
countless different groups are battling
for influence and power to establish
laws and rules that benefit them
in a working democracy there are checks
and balances that are supposed to create
a fair environment where these battles
can be fought
term limits stop factions from
dominating too much
but all of this ends at our borders
international politics are not
democratic but anarchic
no central authority is powerful enough
to ensure fairness or enforce laws so
the only law is the tyranny of the
strongest and anarchy
so for most of human history
powerful countries took what they wanted
from others either by extortion or by
violence
after world war ii the united nations
were founded to overcome this anarchy by
establishing rules on how countries
should behave but since the un has
virtually no power and its members often
have opposing interests it's usually
politely ignored
the eu is a construct that tries to have
rules and laws for its member nations
that are actually enforceable as the
european court of justice is able to
make binding decisions
originally the eu was founded to ensure
peace between european nations and
prosperity for the continent
but it's also an attempt to gain
international power for its members
it's like a super state and it's
striving to be democratic and
legitimized by all of its citizens
to do that it has to solve the problem
of different actors wanting different
things
only that its members are countries with
very different priorities
so how does this work
since the eu is ridiculously complex and
politicians are even worse than
scientists at naming things we'll
simplify massively and omit a lot of
details you can find further reading and
explanations in our sources document
okay
if you want to create a democratic union
of independent nations you have two
options
one
let everybody vote for national
politicians who then make decisions for
the union together or two
let every citizen vote directly for an
independent institution that's able to
make binding decisions
both approaches have their upsides and
downsides and the eu ended up with a mix
of both of them
next to the european court of justice
there are four main institutions that
we'll talk about today
the european council which is made up of
the heads of government or states of the
member countries
the council of the eu with ministers
from the member countries
the third one is the european commission
which is the de facto government of the
eu having one commissioner for each
member state
and lastly the european parliament
the parliament is the only part of the
eu that is directly elected by you dear
citizen in the european elections
in principle all of these institutions
of the eu originate from your direct or
indirect vote be it at the national or
eu level but some do more than others
for example you vote for your national
representative and therefore contribute
to form a national government whose head
of state has a seat in the european
council these leaders choose the
president of the eu commission and its
fellow commissioners who eventually are
confirmed by the eu parliament
so this is a sort of indirect democracy
you didn't vote for the commission but
you voted for the people who appointed
them and for those who confirmed and
policed them
so in effect 2.5 of the four main
european union institutions depend on
the member state governments
but since you as a citizen can only
directly vote for the european
parliament the question is how powerful
is it
how much influence does your vote have
[Music]
the european parliament started out with
very little influence but has become
more and more powerful over the past two
decades
today it has to approve new laws which
can be binding for the member countries
it also votes on how the eu budget is
spent and on international treaties
[Music]
all of this makes the parliament very
powerful and thus your vote very
influential even on an international
level
compared to national parliament one
major power is still missing though
the eu parliament officially can't
propose new laws on its own which is
often the core of the argument the eu is
not democratic enough and that the
european parliament should be given more
influence
right now the member states governments
pretty much control the european union
giving the parliament more power would
make the eu as a whole more democratic
but it would also take power from member
states
it's not clear which approach is better
ultimately it's for the member states
and us as citizens to decide how the
union should develop
ok so can we draw a conclusion here
as a whole the eu is not as democratic
as most of its member states but it is
democratic
if you don't like decisions they make
regarding copyright for example you can
look up what your representatives voted
for and vote them out
the struggle to make it more democratic
is closely tied to who holds power over
what
the eu keeps changing
you dear citizen are not only voting on
the current politics but also on what
the system will look like in the future
there are many parties and politicians
that vowed to make the eu parliament and
therefore your vote stronger
many others want to keep it as it is or
even diminish it it's for you to decide
what you think is better for the future
of the union
currently it's equally important for the
eu who you vote for at home
because these are the people who have
the most influence in the european union
right now
opinion
at home is also where the eu is often
used as a scapegoat politicians
especially before national elections
like to pretend the eu is all-powerful
and makes up rules and laws over the
heads of the governments and citizens
although often they were directly
responsible for what the eu did
democracy is annoying and complicated
and often very boring in the european
union even more so than in the member
states
but voting and caring about how our
political institutions change and
develop is one of the most powerful
things we can do as citizens
the last few years have shown that
extreme things can happen through
elections
we have to decide if we want to be an
active part of this process
if we don't take part in the struggle
for power that is politics others will
and we might not like what they decide
for us
because europe is an important topic for
us we've translated this video into as
many european languages as possible
a couple of european youtubers narrated
it and uploaded it to their own channels
thank you to funk and all youtubers who
helped us you can find the playlist with
all language versions in the description
me
[Music]